why did the relationship end I won't go
into that too much but I will say it was
Mutual Cole Sprouse Dives head first
into his past relationships on the call
her daddy podcast including his breakup
with Riverdale co-star Lily Reinhardt
how did you navigate a breakup with
someone that you work with oh it was
really hard
it's really hard for both of us Lily and
Cole started dating around the time
Riverdale premiered in 2017. whatever
you need to do or explore
I support you their characters Jughead
and Betty also had a romance on the show
popularly known as bug head I mean Betty
and jacket do have a lot of scenes
together so Cole and I do work together
a lot but yeah we're doing we're doing
quite well we really leaned on each
other while also going through the
elected trauma of this incredible
overnight success
um a ton of criticism and I'm very
grateful in very many ways I was able to
go through it with someone who was going
through the exact same set of
circumstances as me but also in very
many ways uh all the cliches about
dating someone you work with are very
true lily and Cole were together for
three years before splitting in 2020.
someone had to have made the first step
to end it I left you left I did thank
you yeah
yeah but to be honest when you're in a
relationship for that long
and someone leaves it's not like
someone's like what
yes there's not it's not a surprise this
was right before covid so it also gave
us the space because we got locked down
that's great you know which I which I
think was good and Cole admits it
probably would have ended a lot sooner
if they weren't working together I mean
there was a lot of pressure
towards other people really I I think if
I had loved myself a little more I
probably I probably would have laughed a
little earlier but
um I uh
I just felt like I had to take care of a
lot of people around me which was not
good for me the romance ended but
Riverdale continued on and for Cole and
Lily things weren't easy at first it's
really hard for both of us and that's
okay the work thing got difficult
because it was hard to suspend all the
way we felt about each other
um
and it didn't afford US the luxury of
distance to really
overcome that
um I know we both did quite a quite a
bit of damage to each other in that
we're good friends now which is awesome
we work really well together now I would
say you know if I were to talk to myself
six years ago I'd be like hey man this
is actually it's gonna be quite big keep
your head on straight goal has since
moved on with girlfriend Ari Fournier
the couple celebrated their two-year
anniversary in January and he says he's
never been happier she's my best friend
we get along so well we do everything
together and as a consequence of our
relationship my life has just improved
foreign